foreign
how could the majority of scientists and
doctors been so wrong regarding covid
and its treatment should we ever trust
them again
um
two points
should we ever trust them again as a
complex question because there's you
know on the one hand no and on the other
hand what choice do we have so the
question is how can we resurrect
medicine so this never happens again and
they can be trusted how can we resurrect
trustworthiness in medicine that's the
question yes
um how could this have happened I think
that's a very interesting story and one
that needs to be explored and we're not
going to do it fully here but I do think
there this episode in history has
revealed some things that we knew that
needed greater uh
Insight you know Mass formation and All
Is Not A New Concept but we've now
understood something about how it
functions that I think certainly many of
us did not know and maybe nobody did
um but
in some sense you had people
uh you know there aren't very many uh
professions with an oath medicine has an
oath right we had
doctors by the hundreds of thousand
violate this oath
how did they do that did they know they
were violating the oath did they violate
a deeper obligation to themselves and
lie to themselves so they wouldn't
violate their professional oath and if
so what is happening now right at what
point how many of them who engaged in
self-deception in order to get through
it are still self-deceived right and at
what point is your self-deception so
willful and egregious that it doesn't
even count as self-deception because you
know that you're running from a truth
that's right in front of you and I don't
know how we deal with this but I will
say
the one piece of actual wisdom I have on
this front is
yes
the vast number of doctors who saw
things understood that there was more to
this puzzle understood that those of us
who were concerned about it were not
crazy and didn't say anything have
in they have engaged in an egregious
breach of trust they did so under duress
right this did not happen in a vacuum
this happened with threats to livelihood
and ability to earn it happened with
threats to reputation there will always
be duress while there will always be
duress and I expect people to um
to stand up under that kind of pressure
because what's what's at stake when it's
doctors who uh Buckle is life right
but
you don't want to rush to the conclusion
that these people are effectively no
longer doctors the question is how can
we confront what happened so that we can
rebuild medicine without having to start
from scratch yeah I guess
I mean I have a lot of questions
and one of the questions that comes to
mind here is
ah given how much evidence there is now
for a variety of forms of early
treatment
in the scientific literature
in empirical experience by many doctors
in the U.S and in the formal protocols
being adopted by many other countries
how do American doctors
[Music]
continue to explain to themselves
justify say to patients
if you get covered the only Avenue open
to you is yet another pharmaceutical
it's called Pax Lovin
how do they do that how how
so so the only way to protect yourself
is one of our
vaccines and the only way to deal with
it once you're sick which you will get
sick even if you get the vaccine it's
not like it helps with that
is PAX lovid
I I
I don't see it I can't I can't I cannot
get
I I I I I just don't know how you could
possibly if you are a practicing doctor
who is actually recommending courses of
action to patients and you are not
telling them
to get in the Sun
and consider laying in especially in the
winter and taking regularly d and c and
magnesium and zinc and having a supply
of melatonin on hand and
still super dicey in the U.S got us
demonetized but for [ __ ] sake
hydroxychloroquine and Ivermectin yep
are
good treatment yep and they're good
early treatment and almost everyone else
in the world knows this
what is going on
yeah and that's half the story too
because at the same time that they are
recommending uh the dangerous novel
pharmaceutical and failing to recommend
the things that actually work they are
also continuing to recommend vaccination
when increasingly doctors have the
evidence in front of them of people who
have maladies that they shouldn't have
yeah and you know okay also the doctors
who are doing these recommendations
you have a patient in front of you
that patient has some number of
comorbidities
some of which they can take control of
with changes to diet and lifestyle
that's what you encourage them to do you
do not pretend that you fix your health
with pills and you keep on doing all the
crap things that you are doing all of us
do things we shouldn't do and which
impair our health all of us make
decisions that are bad sometimes this is
not about blaming the obese or blaming
the people with diabetes or with kidney
failure or anything but
many of these conditions have in them an
element which can be improved with
changes that the individual can take
with regard to their behavior and the
choices they make
be doing that and their doctor should be
telling them they should be doing that
yeah not simply writing a script in fact
um it is dereliction of Duty it is
dereliction of Duty and this goes way
before coven yes right the fact is
preventive medicine is not a New Concept
it is obviously the right thing to be uh
advocating and a system yes that is
hell-bent on waiting for you to get sick
diagnosing your sickness quickly and
throwing a pill at you without regard
for its uh side effects
um that's obviously not a system
interested in your health and this is
precisely what
um you know the allopathic medicine the
MDS are much more likely to do the like
I'll just write you a script and it
might deal with your symptoms Maybe not
maybe I'll see you for another 10
minutes and six months maybe not
um but you know we started the show our
new sponsor this this outfit wisdom
Health that is helping connect
um functional medicine doctors with
patients that's most of us that's going
to be naturopaths
um and I can say now having dealt
extensively pre-covered you know forget
coveted for the moment if you can
um
that the allopathic medicine industry uh
is largely very confused on questions of
evolution and diagnosis and you're far
more likely to find people who are
willing to and interested in thinking
and in actually laying hands on your
body and figuring out what is going on
with you over an osteopath and
naturopath territory much more likely
yep I agree yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]